- [Female Voice] In supply cost, right?
- In supply.
- [Female Voice] Right.
- I love it.
(onstage speaker static)
- [Female Voice] Sorry guys, was that me?
- Probably.
(piano music)
- (mumbles) ...in energies, like...
First and foremost happy
birthday, Tamara Vaynerchuk.
Happy birthday, Mom, hope
you have the best day ever,
can't wait to see you
later today in Philly,
about to rip faces off in
this city of brotherly love.
Heart, exclamation point.
- Hi.
- Did you get some sleep?
- I got a little bit, yeah.
- Oh, good, good, good.
- Yeah, it was good.
- Ready to do back to back?
- I am.
(piano music)
(electronic humming)
- [Tyler] Question from Dean.
Giving up is hard, but
sometimes you're in too deep.
- That's a great question (mumbles),
and the answer is I can't
answer that for you,
I really can't.
That's an incredibly thoughtful question.
Look, 99% of people give
up at the proper time.
99.
But 1% give up a week before
they would've "made it."
I think you look at past results
to tell you future results,
but other times things turn.
You know, it's a feeling one
has to know when it's time,
when it's time in life in general,
and I think some people are good at it,
I think some people are bad at it.
And so what I would say is
the most important thing
I think about is: you would
never know the alternative.
If you stop, because
it hasn't been working,
and you've been patient
for three and a half years,
but now you think you've
crossed over into delusion,
you'll just never know.
And I'm okay with that.
There's so many things
I "could have done,"
so many paths that I could've taken.
Some people are pessimistic,
look at glass half empty,
and always think back "I
should've married that person,
I should've took that job,
I should've invested in that stock."
I just don't have that gear,
and I would spend much more
time on having the gear
of being optimistic and
knowing that you can't
control the past.
Or that you won't know the
alternative of your decisions
and that makes you more
optimistic and positive and happy
and go forward and faster.
I think it's about the
mindset of knowing that
you would've never known otherwise.
More so than what's the right time or not.
Nobody can answer you.
Not that, not me, not nobody.
You just have to answer for yourself.
Play the hand, and move on, period.
End of story.
The end.
No matter how much
content you're producing,
for whatever you're trying to achieve,
whether that's to raise money for the PTA
or sell sneakers,
or build your real estate firm,
or whatever you do.
The one thing for all of the
people here in the front,
and all those homies that
I love so much in the back,
(audience cheers)
Man, it takes a while for
noise to get the f*ck up here.
Sh*t is crazy.
All the good sh*t that's going on with me
I literally think I mean nothing.
I am being dead serious with you.
I think I'm the greatest of all time
with my confidence and
bravado and ego and excitement
and the things that I see are happening,
but I equally know that if
I disappeared tomorrow...
Cool, I'd have a good social media day.
And then everyone would...
I'm telling you when
Prince and David Bowie died
in that little window,
and I watched those icons of culture
get about 24 hours of love
and then everybody forgot.
I was like "f*ck," right?
I mean it, I mean it.
And so, what's really empowering,
and what's holding so
many people back here,
is entitlement.
You feel like somebody owes you something
because something went wrong
somewhere along the way.
I don't.
I actually think whatever
went wrong for you
is the best sh*t that ever happened to you
because adversity is absolutely
the foundation of success.
(audience cheers and applauds)
The other thing I know is I have bad news.
Nobody gives a f*ck about your problems.
(audience whoops)
And this is super important to understand.
The second you actually understand
that nobody actually gives a shit...
The only people that
listen to you complaining
are your loser f*cking friends.
(audience laughs)
If you like complaining,
like just take a step back.
Look around the next time
you're complaining about
the government, or you know
racial, or feminine, or...
I had a guy sit in front
of me the other day
crying that his life was bad
because he was a white male.
(audience laughs)
Rich white male.
I was like "oh sh*t, we've
gone everywhere now."
(audience laughs)
You're either on the offense or defense.
I just want you to know something.
One of the things that's
been really on my mind
is I think a lot of people
think they're in the middle.
They're like, in transit.
You're only on the offense or the defense.
And I've realized that
I've been on the offense
my whole life because I never
felt entitled to anything.
An incredible thing
happens when you're born
with very little.
You know, I was born in the Soviet Union,
we come to America, I live in
a studio apartment in Queens.
You know, "my parents bought me six toys
in my entire life" kind of of thing.
We took one, one family
vacation in my entire life.
Right?
When I wanted Nintendo my mom
looked me dead in the face
and said "good, go buy it."
And that was huge.
On the flip side, what she also did
was she instilled...
Let me rephrase.
She reinforced things
that came natural to me
and made them the most important things.
While I was getting Ds and Fs
and every other immigrant
parent was making their kids
get As and Bs because they
thought that's what mattered,
my mom was accelerating
and going out of her mind
any time that I showed compassion,
any time that I showed empathy,
any time that I showed gratitude,
and honestly for all of you that watch me
it's what I'm doing for my
community with my content.
We, my friends, more than ever now...
We need to focus on the truth.
Here's the truth.
This second that we're sitting here
is the greatest second
in the history of mankind
for Human beings.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I love this woman so much.
So f*cking much.
- I'm just trying to get this...
I just want it out so bad,
I'm just trying to get it out.
- And so, what, you guys are still
post-productioning?
- Well...
- You're tweaking it?
Or like, what's holding you back?
- Trying to find like, the correct way
to put it out.
- Got it.
Give it the most noise possible?
- Yeah.
- Guys, I'm telling you.
It's Instagram accounts.
Whether it's World Star,
whether it's Gary V,
whether it's Yattie,
whether it's, you know.
It's just, it's Instagram accounts.
Like just, go in a cocoon and get like
50 people that have
love for you and be like
"Yeah we will put out the
first one or the third one"
or "these 10 people are
doing the first one,"
I remember you were doing it
in that kind of way, like.
That's what it is.
- (mumbles)
- There's like,
ten people on Instagram can
do more for you than f*cking,
like, dot com, like,
it's a different game.
- Yeah...
- It's literally the
f*cking talk I just gave.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, no I know.
- Yeah...
- Like, you get Ninja to f*cking like,
while he's playing Fortnite, be like
"oh, this is phat, look here,"
that's all you need!
- Yeah...
- I'm comfortable in both.
Like if you had 14 millions
followers on Instagram
you wouldn't be thinking about this
you'd just put on your own shit.
- Yeah...
- That's true.
- You guys have so many people, like me,
that know what you're about to be.
It's good for them.
They either like you or they
know you're going to be huge.
I'm both, so I'm easy.
But they're either one or the other,
and that's selfish for them.
- Yeah...
- Just gotta sit down a go into a bunker
and start asking.
- Thank you so much, I
hope to see you soon, okay?
- I can't wait to see you.
- Thank you.
- Ring me up any time, love you.
- (mumbles) once you see the whole thing.
- Can't wait.
(audience cheers)
My man, what's your name?
- [Male Audience Member] How're
you doing today (mumbles)?
People love to (mumbles)
you know what I'm saying?
(mumbles)
- That's right.
- (mumbles)
- Thank you.
Thank you, man, listen you're right.
"People" love to play the part, right?
People love to play the part.
Like it's the same way about
keyboard warriors, let's go
that I told you about, like people...
Pleasure.
(audience laughs)
Gotcha.
- Thank you...
- Yo, you just rolled up
like f*cking crazy up in here
that's what's up.
Hey, guy, how are you?
- I had to, bro, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Got you?
- My son wanna say "hi," too.
- Good, bring him.
So here's my thing,
and for, again, for you
to be at this conference.
Some of you who follow
me, you guys know this:
I love when people e-mail me and say
They're not watching me anymore.
"I'm done with you Gary V."
I'm thrilled.
I'm not in here to monetize my audience.
I get sad when they're like "okay,"
because I say it a lot,
like "stop watching me
and go do you."
Like, how many more
motivational books do you need?
How many more videos do you have to watch?
Like, what you're doing is getting a short
second euphoria kind of
feeling cause you feel like
you're on the verge of doing something.
But it's only about the doing something.
And unfortunately there's
a lot of people making
a lot of money making you
feel good for a few seconds.
I literally think about
"motivation" and things like that
the way I think about the
drug industry in America:
we're not "fixing sh*it,"
we're just making money
on pausing sh*t, or stretching sh*t out.
I would be thrilled if
you never bought a book,
never watched a video,
my concern is a lot of
times people say that to me
and then I watch because
I'm always curious.
I said it earlier,
"I don't watch you
anymore Gary V, I got it,"
but then they're watching
somebody else that's
a diluted version of it.
They just wanted to say to
me they don't watch anymore,
You know?
It's doing.
You can't read about doing push ups.
You gotta do 'em.
And then you get the results.
- [Female Audience Member]
So I've been doing this
for 11 years, I speak Chinese.
So basically, I'm the girl who goes there
makes sure the orders are placed,
and I actually teach people how to
do their business effectively
in supply cost, right?
- In supply?
- [Female Audience Member] Right.
- I love it.
- [Female Audience Member] So basically...
Sorry guys, is that me?
- Probably.
- [Female Audience Member]
Alright, so that's one thing.
The other thing I do is
I teach people how to do
personal, private, and business (mumbles).
(mumbles)
So I'm trying to package all...
- Put it all on there.
- [Female Audience Member] Yeah!
- Put it all out there.
Like...
People overthink it.
Dumb people are telling you things like
start three accounts
this, that, and the other thing.
But put it all out there.
You are you, you are you.
I post shit about wine on my account.
Not everybody, like, 98%
of my audience on Instagram
doesn't want to see me
talking about a wine.
They're there to get motivated,
or a trick, or a business thing.
I don't give a fuck.
I want to talk about wine.
And guess what?
Some of them want to buy wine, too.
They're tired of buying dumb
shit, especially when you
live in a bullsh*t
state like Pennsylvania.
Liquor control, bullsh*it.
Anyway, so, you know?
Tell all your truths.
- [Female Audience
Member] What would you say
to those people who say
"focus on just one thing?"
- I don't know, look,
my big thing is this.
Always look at the
person giving the advice.
That's my advice.
Show me who's giving you the other advice.
I'm very fascinated by this.
People are always like,
"Gary, but this person told me
to do this," and I'm like,
what the f*ck is that person doing?
And first of all, f*ck my advice: do you.
- [Female Audience Member] That's right.
- Forget about Gary V or
Sally F*cking Thompson,
do you.
You want to talk about
f*cking supply chain
from China today?
Post.
You want to fucking
write a LinkedIn article
today about real estate?
Post.
You want to f*cking film you
on Beijing Air f*cking landing?
Post.
(audience laughs)
My dear, everybody here is overthinking
at the cost of doing.
Everybody here is either
overthinking and using
perfectionism as an excuse to not do.
The doing.
It's only the doing, got it?
I gotta go, see ya.
I'm sorry, I gotta catch a truth.
(audience applause)
Real quick, real quick.
- [Announcer] Please give it up for...
- Good to see you again, brother.
- Have a good day,
we'll see you (mumbles).
- Thank you so much, take care.
It's crazy how much I
like people interaction.
- [Male Voice] I know, even just like...
- I just think, yeah...
I was just like thinking,
I'm like "it's so interesting
how much that is my currency."
You know?
It just feels nice, I think
it's a nice thing to do.
To like acknowledge someone
else and be like "what's up?"
You know? So like that...
Even did you see how he reacted?
- [Male Voice] Yeah.
- Just like nothing
crazy, but just like not
so unexpected and nice.
- [Airline Voice Over] Regional...
- Being you for an hour every year.
- That's cool.
- And not tell anyone
until like (mumbles).
- That's cool, I'm into that.
I would do that, that's a good idea.
That's a way better idea than I thought
was going to come out of your mouth.
- I don't know why...
- No, I mean it was a really good idea.
- I know, I don't
understand the (mumbles).
- Yeah.
- I'm going to f*cking sh*t my pants.
- How are you?
- Oh my god.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Oh my god my husband is
going to be so jealous.
- Nice meeting you.
- Nice meeting you, thanks.
- Take care, you're welcome.
- Yeah, I need to send a
picture to Badgely and them.
- Sure.
Awesome.
- Alright (mumbles).
- Nice meeting you guys.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, a real pleasure.
(Mumbles), yeah take care.
(laughter)
That's such a good piece of content.
We never do that, we never
do anything, like, funny.
Like, nothing like bro banter, you know?
So funny.
- What'd you do?
- It was just.
I made a good face.
I used my comedic capabilities.
(laughter)
What was that like...
Is that a challenge
like, "you can't get it
out of my hand?"
Victories here against me in tennis.
True?
- True.
- And lot of defeats.
- No true, not even tried yet.
- I've seen him.
- I feel like that's a
20-piece junior content.
- (mumbles) like June 16th I'm
about to put it on the board.
- Take your shirt off.
Take your shirt off or you're (mumbles).
- Either take your shirt off, or.
- Hey, take your shirt
off right here and now,
show me that you got something.
(laughter)
what?
What, nothing.
I was just looking at you.
This is what the VLOG should be.
(laughter)
Just the constant razzing.
- (mumbles) Hey, how you doing?
- Hey, how are you?
- I'm a (mumbles) nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Hey I tried to catch
up with you when you were
out at (mumbles) last year.
Didn't get a chance to, but
just wanted to say, you know
(mumbles)
You're pretty awesome.
- Send me an Email to Gary
(mumbles) and we can get back
if you give me your card.
(calm R&B music)
People's help at night
that sit in that area,
like getting Justin and Sophie,
like you need to figure
it the f*ck out bro.
Straight up.
(calm R&B music)
See ya, good trip.
Secret wine project?
(mumbles) we accomplished, good key note.
Funny, funny moment, with D-Rock.
Happy birthday mama, I love you so much.
(calm R&B music)